five enormous galaxies locked in a
cosmic dance billions of stars and
planets 300 million light years from
earth
this is one of the spectacular images
taken by the webb space telescope
unveiled for the first time
what you're seeing is just
a week's worth of data think what we're
going to learn in 20 years
think of the answers that we're going to
get to the questions we don't even know
enough to know what the questions are
today
and in the process
we're going to learn more about who we
are
what we are what is
our
existence in this cosmos
we are looking back in time
almost to the beginning the image of the
so-called stefan's quintet shows two
galaxies colliding and merging with one
another impelled by the force of gravity
one of the galaxies features a bright
spot scientists have identified as an
active black hole the gas and dust
lighting up as it spills into the
gravitational event horizon this image
shows a stellar nursery with brightly
shining new stars being born at the edge
of a vast region of gas and dust this is
the carina nebula which is part of our
own milky way galaxy the level of detail
showing structures and bubbles in the
enormous cloud is finer than any other
telescope is capable of this image shows
a dying binary star surrounded by
superheated hydrogen gas and other
materials spun off from the star's core
elements which will reform into other
stars planets and perhaps in time living
things
webb which was launched in december is a
joint project of nasa and the european
and canadian space agencies it took more
than 20 years to build and cost 10
billion dollars it's the most
sophisticated space telescope ever made
and makes observations in the infrared
spectrum a wavelength of light not
visible to the human eye scientists were
awed by the first images
maybe people in a broken world
managing to do something right and to
see some of the majesty that's out there
finally this image gives a sense of the
incomprehensible vastness of space and
time it is a deep look at a single area
teeming with galaxies and stars the
light seen here originated 13 billion
years ago less than a billion years
after the big bang
scientists promise many more discoveries
are ahead adding immeasurably to our
understanding of the universe that we
are a part of rob reynolds al jazeera